نقلت وكاله رويترز عن المتحدث باسم
السفاره الصينيه في واشنطن النبيين تعارض
بحزم عبور المدمره الامريكيه تشانغ هون
مضيق تايوان امس وتدعو واشنطن للكف فورا
على ثوره المتاعب وتصعيد التوتر والاضرار
بالسلام والاستقرار في منطقه سيوان
انها نشرت قواته لمراقبه
التحركات كانت تحت السيطره
وكان سلاح البحريه الامريكيه كشف ان
المدمر التشنج هونا المجاوره بصوارخ موجهه
نفذت عمليه عبور روتينيه في مضيق تايوان
سفينه عبرت المضيق من ممر يقع خارج المياه
الاقليميه لاي دوله ساحليه
المتحده بمنطقه المحيطين الهندي
من بجين مدير مكتبه الجزيره ناصر عبد الحق
ينضم الينا للمزيد حول تفاصيل الموقف
الصيني وهل هو ايضا ضمن سياق التصعيده
عموما في هذه المنطقه
الاولى التي تعبر فيها فيها قطع عسكريه
امريكيه من مضيق تايوان فقد تعبت الولايات
المتحده ومن يعني تصفهم الصين بانهم
حلفاءها مثل بريطانيا وكندا ده ابو على
المرور من هذا المضيق بقطاعهم البحريه
وطالما ان طعدت وغضبت الصين من مثل هكذا
تصرف
وانتقدت هذه الدول كونها تعتبر مضيق
تايوان من منطقه بحريه اقليميه تابعه لها
ولا يحق لها لهذه القطع البحريه المرور
فيها بينما في المقابل تعتبرها الولايات
المتحده همم منطقه عامه ودوليه وكما ذكرتم
في الخبر بانها ملتزمه كما عبرت انه
ملتزمه بحريه الملاحه في المنطقه البحريه
وال همم هذه المنطقه
عاده ما تشرد العديد من التوتر وخاصه خلال
الفتره الاخيره حيث شاهدنا مناورات صينيه
همم تقريبا شبه يوميا همم ترسل الصين من
خلالها همم عددا من الطائرات الى المنطقه
وتحم بالقرب من جزيره تايوان وهناك ايضا
طائرات امريكيه في الماضي قبل فتره همم
طائرات مراقبه وطائرات استطلاع كانت تمر
ايضاقات كانت تراقبها الصين عن كذا يذكر
ان منطقه
تايوان همم تمتد لتصل الى منطقه بحر جنوب
الصين التي يعتبرها المراقبون في الوقت
الحاليا يعني يتجمع فيه عدد كبير من
القطاع البحريه سواء الامريكيه او الصينيه
او من الدول الاخرى وبالتالي هي منطقه
حساسه للغايه
وكونها تجري فيها العديد من المناورات من
قبل جميعا هذه الاعتراف يتخوف المراقبون
من ان يكون هناك اي احتكاك بين هذه القوات
فاي احتكاك يحدث ربما يشعل شراره في
المنطقه فعلى سبيل المثال همم قبل فتره
وجيزه كان هناك اعتراض لطائره صينيه طائره
صينيه طائره امريكيه فوق تايوان ولكنها لم
تقوم باي يعني اللي ناكل تحرش بهذه
الطائره ولكن همم
الجانب الامريكي
اعرب عن رفضه مثل هذه الاعتراض هذه
الاعتراضات للطائرات اذا المنطقه هي
برمتها تشهد حاله من التوتر غير المسبوق
وجميع الاطراف يعني في حاله همم انتباه
كامله
اسرع من الحق